to begin with I just want to ask you
about the if you can share the
interesting story of how you two first
met my version of it is that I was
teaching at NYU grad film school Laura
was a student there never one of my
students but I saw Laura's short film I
thought I saw it you're saying I saw it
in the editing room
maybe that is right first time and so
anyway I guess that's what it was I
thought it was hysterically funny we
should just clarify is this the you saw
her short film Doris in off the turn it
was called Doris it is called Doris in
the intern and I just thought it was so
funny I'd never met Laura before and she
just said what do you think and she was
working in you know editing in first
year directing exercise yeah what do you
think what could I do differently and I
don't know I remember like I had one
suggestion which is that we like not see
his pants like that we think he's naked
fully naked when he's she didn't take
the note but uh and then I think we then
we kind of became friendly we would see
each other in the hallways literally and
and chat and then over he'll be bonded
over Hal Ashby and then at a certain
point I think I I suggested DeLauro if
you have a thought would maybe want to
write something I would be interested in
that and then we we started talking
about working on something we threw a
bunch of ideas out we focused in on
doing something with the Doris character
we literally wrote almost an entire
movie that's just completely different
movie than this with Doris in the main
role and then scrapped it and kind of
basically said let's let's actually go
to the the basic premise of the short
which is that it's that it's this Doris
character she's infatuated with the
younger man and that's where we kind of
from that sprang the movie that now
exists and Laura anything you want to
add to that love to hear but also what
was the was there a specific inspiration
for the character and the short when at
first when you first were dealing with
her where did she come from well so the
character you know I basically I write
comedies and I wanted to
right anew comedic character and I think
of comedy as the juxtaposition of
opposites and you know positioning this
this older woman having a crush on this
younger man I love of may-december
romance and so that was sort of where
that came from but it was very much a an
exercise it was like a sketch you know
it was like a napkin that you doodle on
a napkin versus this and when Michael
and I started working together you know
it was really about peeling away the
layers and and sort of seeing who Doris
was like how did this woman come into
the world because we knew we had the
comedic premise down but finding the the
truth in the heart of this woman was
really what you know what the challenge
was
so why though for in terms of directing
a feature I think it's been since 2005
you you this is the first time since
then what made you feel that this was
the one to come and back come back and
do that way it wasn't as thought-out as
that it wasn't planned out like that at
all I mean part of it was just that no
one no one was offering me a job to
direct anything I mean I would have
gladly directed a million things in
between but um I when we wrote the movie
we weren't even it wasn't even like
we're gonna write this and you're gonna
direct it it was that kind of happened
as we started as we got this script as
we were getting closer and closer to
like this this is we're finished with
this script now and it's good we and
I'll quickly say this won't be
interesting to anybody but the script
that we first sent out is really really
different than the movie and I'm saying
like in three months it changed entirely
why is that because the the first script
that we sent out to try to get financing
for was really a dark comedy it didn't
have almost all of the more serious
elements in it it was it wasn't arch
comedic Lee but like the last the the
Doris character never we'd never really
got to any of those deeper things
you know it was you know I'm talking
about that doris goes to produce goes to
prison and and yeah and then but then
when red crown who financed the movie
agreed to finance the movie it was like
we want to make the movie but we want
you to strip away and get to the that's
the kind of stuff that we feel like is
missing like you're kind of hinting at
it but we want you to really bring that
out so in two you know it probably took
us two years to write that first draft
and then in three months we like added
all of the more serious stuff to it
including a completely new ending how
much of a consideration wasn't when you
guys are doing this that there aren't a
lot of feature films made about
characters over a certain age
particularly women over a certain age
and I mean this is Sally Fields first
leading role in over a decade what were
you thinking about those things when
you're doing it or you just had faith
that there would be interest in it
regardless I never knew if there would
be interest in it or not I mean I think
that I kind of approached it like in a
very student like way but we knew that
we knew that it was we knew that it was
unconventional and in a way it was like
that could be a good thing you know I
mean I think we weren't we weren't
unaware of that that was potentially a
selling point I you know it was it was
gonna be the thing that was gonna make
it challenging but also the thing that
in success could could help us and there
was no that wasn't a that wasn't like a
strategy it was that you know which we
loved the character but it was like
maybe we could do this you know like we
knew it was a character that has never
yeah oh yeah I mean that was and that
was exciting that was excited and we
felt like it was a good part we felt
like actresses might want to do it you
know it was that kind of a thing so how
did Sally end up in the lead and also
the rest of the sketch terrific ensemble
and some of them in very small parts but
had it had it had come together
well max Greenfield attached himself to
it very early on max is a friend of mine
I had worked with him on another movie
and he was the first person on board
when we when we offered it to say we we
have like a window to make the movie
which was the summer of 2014 I think and
so I was very afraid to send the script
to Sally because I didn't think she
would do it and and I didn't want I was
afraid that we would take forever
because she's a big huge giant movie
star and even though she's the only
person we would have ever wanted to play
the role it was it was kind of scary but
everyone was like we just let's just
take a chance you know and and she
obviously wanted to do the movie and
then once you have Sally Field it's kind
of easy to get those other actors
I mean you to be able to say to all the
other actors that are in the movie this
movie is financed and Sally Field was
playing the lead it piques their
interest and so it what you know it was
a that at that point it was about you
know availability and the actors
obviously needing to respond to the
material but that helps you get in the
door really easily so we were just able
to just look at actors that we loved and
say hey this person would be amazing
Tyne Daly or Steven route or you know
Wendy mclendon-covey or all these
amazing great funny dramatic actors that
we got for the movie we just made them
offers and and and so that's kind of how
it happened so the production three
weeks three and a half right now we did
three weeks in LA and three days in New
York how does that what does that feel
like when you're in the middle of it
it was a very business it was a fun set
but it was not a loose set and that was
a function of that we were obviously
under incredible time constraints but
also Sally Field set a tone right off
the bat that was like everybody get
ready where we're gonna work really hard
on this I'm gonna work really hard and
you guys need to like meet me there and
so we were we were very focused serious
hard-working of not a lot of talking not
a lot of joking around camaraderie and
closeness but it was a very intense I
would say would you agree with that
absolutely
yeah and Sally I mean she was she's in
every scene of the movie pretty much so
to just watch her we put in these you
know 12-hour days where she's in every
single scene you know moving her chair
around this I mean it was just she's
unbelievable yeah and obviously she does
physical work and you know she did she
does she's dancing and she's she's good
the crying scenes or you know very
physically taxing and the costume all
the costume changes that she's doing and
it was exhausting for her I can't even
imagine emotionally like we're shooting
completely out of order and so she you
know has her marked script and is going
from a scene that's very comedic tonally
to a scene that's very dramatic totally
in the course of two hours but her
script would literally say sort of like
he knew exactly where she know we would
be shooting it was almost like she made
a chart and so it would be like she knew
kind of where what her level needed to
be because it's true we would maybe on
the day that we shot the scene where the
family comes over and that big break
dancing I'm sure we were doing comedy
scenes on that same day so I guess the
last thing which I'd like to ask each of
you to answer is what have you made now
that it started to roll out I guess a
week ago in New York and LA and now
wider what have you made of responses to
it sort of most meaningful funny
interesting whatever and then also if it
was up to you to sort of single out what
you hope people take away from this
because it is an unconventional type of
story we don't see this let what what
that would be so Laurie are you want to
sir so I mean for me a lot of what the
film is about is visibility and how in
our culture older women sort of become
invisible and Doris would not go down
without a fight you know and when sort
of that's to me what you know but I
wanted to look at with this film and and
so I'm and I I'm really pleased with the
responses people seem to appreciate it
on both the comedic level and a dramatic
one and so yeah I couldn't be happier
and and for me I would say that there's
a theme for the movie it's that it's
never too late to start something and
it's possible to change and in terms of
the response I mean I'm happy extremely
gratified that Sally Fields performance
is being recognized that's so that's
really all I care about
you know and it's I mean it's amazing
it's amazing to to to see people I don't
I'm you know it's amazing to go to a
movie theater and be like there's people
here in the movie theater just because
they want to see the movie not because
they're my friends or my family and I
had to beg them to come see it you know
like it's a crazy feeling to be like
they're just here because they want to
see the movie and and so as the person
who knows the people making the movie
that's like you can't that's that is the
greatest feeling ever is to know that
like they're there really because they
just want to be there they want to see
Sally Field playing this role and it's
great thank you very much thank you for
coming thanks for coming